cette cliente vient de faire une bonne
affaire pour l'achat de sa nouvelle
voiture
elle a bénéficié de la prime à la
reconversion c'est une réduction de
combien donc finalement ça fait combien
en pleine crise de gilet jaune
le gouvernement a donc décidé de
prolonger le dispositif en place
et mieux encore de le rendre plus
attractif avec des primes multiplié par
deux mais attention l'accès à cette
prime allant de 1000 à 5000 euros dépend
de plusieurs critères que vous soyez
imposables au nom de la distance entre
votre domicile et votre travail et du
modèle que vous souhaitez acheter qu'il
s'agisse d'un véhicule diesel essence
hybride ou électrique
en outre pour bénéficier d'une prime
doublée
cela se complique encore vous devez être
non imposable avec un revenu fiscal du
foyer inférieur ou égal à 6300 euros et
résider à 30 km de votre lieu de travail
plutôt peu fréquent en martinique
vous aurez alors droit à une prime de
4000 euros pour un véhicule essence et
5000 euros pour un hybride des critères
qui porte également sur le véhicule dont
vous souhaitez vous débarrasser
si vous avez une essence il faut que le
véhicule soit d'avant 97
gisèle non imposable c'est avant 2006 et
jay z imposable serre avant 2020
les gens sont pas vraiment renseigné
concernant les primes qu'on fait avant
la primaire en conversion c'est quand
j'arrive au bureau on leur explique
comment ça fonctionne autant de
conditions qui réduisent l'accès aux
dispositifs dans cette concession
il a représenté à peine 6% des ventes
l'an dernier
je pense que ça aura le même type de co2
d'impact sur 2018 ster que ça va pas
générer 1
ça va pas générer un impact énorme mais
par contre c'est l'effet d'aubaine c'est
à dire que les gens vont profiter de ça
pour pouvoir se débarrasser d'un vieux
véhicule pour des clientes qui était
dans le cas limite à fin 2010 8 qui ont
attendu 2010 pour pouvoir profiter de la
prime ce qui est normal le gouvernement
a prévu un budget de 600 millions
d'euros pour financer le dispositif
c'est 20 % de plus que l'an dernier
en 2018 les concessionnaires automobiles
avaient subi de nombreux retards de
paiement